[Music]
believe it or not this is session 31 in
this nearly monthly series we've been
doing for almost three years
worlds of speculative fiction so this
time we have Jack Vance's dying earth
series this is the omnibus that I little
bit before it's got the four dying earth
stories stories novels you know well
actually not even novels because the
first and the last are essentially a
whole bunch of things put together so
collections of short stories and then
two novels I guess you could say in the
the middle of it and written at
different times but but very important
for for Vance's work and the only the
only thing that I created for today was
actually the timeline which is quite
long because Vance lived into his 90s
and was was active even into his 90s so
you know what we do in this is talk
about world building and the setting and
then philosophical themes I have some
picked out but I know that you guys will
have some as well that you want to talk
about and there's a lot of biography to
talk about with with Vance himself quite
an interesting guy and then there's you
know quite a bit to say about the
characters and the just what exactly is
the dying earth and what makes it
distinctive so you know I think you know
you can you guys can tell me what you
read I know I encountered Vance when I
was in I think high school and was you
know for reading short stories I think
I'd read some of his stuff already in
some anthologies and I encountered some
of the dying earth stuff back then and
then left it alone and came back to it
again I think this was something that
somebody else had suggested to for the
series I don't remember exactly who and
I'm happy to do it it did take a bit to
get into the the first book I found
going back to at the dying earth itself
took a little bit to get moving with it
in part one of the things you'd brought
up last time was the with some of these
authors they they throw
so many words at you in such complex you
know arrangements that that at times
unless you have the time you actually
like really sit down with it it's it's
not light reading but then after you get
used to it then then it starts moving
along a bit so Vance himself let's talk
about his biography first he is a
Californian and he's born in San
Francisco his dad was apparently a
rancher does not stick around long
there's it's hard to tell exactly
whether they hate they divorced or just
separated but his dad goes down to
Mexico and takes off and so his mother
moves him and and his four siblings down
to their grandfathers California ranch
near Oakley up and up in these nice
hills and he's a really precocious kid
he enters high school aged eleven they
would do things like that back then
the year that he graduates from high
school his grandfather dies and that's a
big catastrophe for the family because
you notice it sits right in the start of
the depression the grandfather is the
main source of income so jack is out
there at age fifteen taking a whole
succession of jobs traveling from place
to place in California by the way I
think a lot of other people were as well
a few years later after working a number
of jobs that he didn't particularly care
for he gets a small scholarship and he
starts studying at the University of
California Berkeley you notice that he
doesn't just stick with one topic he
jumps around quite a bit he actually
doesn't stay in school yeah well he does
three semesters and then he decides he
wants to go and do something else that
he goes to Hawaii and he's at Pearl
Harbor working as an electricians
assistant and he said it was pretty
terrible so he left and it's kind of
fortunate that he did because he wasn't
there when Pearl Harbor got bombed then
you know after Pearl Harbor gets bombed
he tries to enlist in the Navy but his
eyesight is bad
so they won't take him and he starts
working in the Kaiser shipyard and in
Richmond
he doesn't roll in an army intelligence
program to learn Japanese he does learn
some Japanese but he doesn't he doesn't
finish the program and then he joins the
Merchant Marine and there's a little
story about how he managed to do that
he actually memorized the eye exam he
knew what the eye exam would look like
so he went in and he found an
optometrists whatever it was you know
and then went in and took the eye exam
and they they let him in and while he's
in the Merchant Marine he starts having
a lot of time on his hands he's at sea
and so he starts writing stories and
some of them are these these stories
that will be the first ones in the the
dying earth and then he starts you know
one once he's out he starts publishing
stories his career was kind of mixed
into really into the 70s he he wrote for
a lot of pulps he didn't get a lot of
success with the things that he was
writing and so like you know quite a few
other successful writers he would say
well where can I actually make some
money where can I lay on something and
so he did a good bit of mystery writing
sometimes under pseudonyms some
adventure writing the stuff that he
wasn't he didn't hate but it wasn't his
his favorite and you know when people
asked him about this he was very down to
earth he said well you you know got to
be able to earn a living as a writer so
you take whatever you can and in 46 he
meets his his wife Norma in gold starts
writing these these stories and novels
for Ellery Queen some of you may know
that mystery it's not a mystery to
author because a whole bunch of people
wrote under Ellery Queen you know sir I
guess what would you call it like a
consortium or
a stable of ghostwriters yaks yeah I
mean they and they edited it well you
know I wonder you know this is totally
off topic but one of the one of the
series that I read a lot as a kid was
Tom Swift I don't I don't remember who
wrote it but I wonder if it was the same
sort of deal where it was like a whole
bunch of people churning these stories
out because yeah that must have been a
big thing bang yeah well you know where
I you know I grew up out in Wales and
and we'd go to the Delafield public
library and they had a whole shelf of
these things and so I just like read my
way through them over the course of the
summer and they're all basically the
same story you know Tom invents
something the I think it was the Bergen
Didion's or the bad guys or something
like that is some weird name and they're
supposed to be the Russians they'd steal
it he and his friend bud would go and
get it back and bud would punch somebody
and that was pretty much it
you know and and the vans he had to
write some some stuff like that here and
there but he keeps on writing and he's
sending things to different pulps he
does get connected with John Campbell
and being connected with him was pretty
important back then because he was a
major editor he did land a few more with
Campbell the Campbell didn't really like
Vance and as a matter of fact I haven't
read this but apparently the
correspondence between them is really
something to check out because Vance was
not happy about having as his stories
turned down so I'll have to check that
out sometime he starts writing these
other stories though the Magnus Rudolph
series for startling stories they open a
ceramic shop for a little while then
they close it and the madness Rudolph
stories are going to become useful later
on as we'll see
and then Damon Knight is somebody
he connects with and another major you
know figure in the editorial process of
speculative fiction and he buys three
advances stories and then he asked Vance
hey we've got a book series coming up do
you have a book and the answer if
anybody ever asks you do you have a book
and you got to be able to say yes even
if you don't actually have a book and so
that was the first of the books of the
dying earth if it's a fix up alright
we've talked about the fix up genre you
take a bunch of stories put them
together and say there's there's my book
a van Voight was somebody who did a lot
of those but some of the other authors
that we've looked at were too and so the
dying earth comes out and then something
really interesting happens 21st Century
Fox buys the film rights to this story
hard luck diggings and the higher
advance as a scriptwriter
so the Vance's move to Hollywood and
apparently the the movie turns out
terribly nothing nothing goes right but
they get their money upfront which is
also very smart as well and then they
after that that is over with they go to
Europe they they start traveling around
and they stay in Europe until the money
runs out and then they come back and
then he starts looking for more work
and he takes a scriptwriting job and I
and I did find some interesting things
about this captain video and his video
Rangers so I don't know anything about
this show and I'm sure there's probably
some footage of it out there somewhere
but apparently it was it was a show that
had been steadily declining in quality
and this is in the very early years of
television so you've got to imagine it
probably started out okay and then just
like started going completely downhill
and it wasn't just Vance who was brought
in to work on this Arthur Clarke was
brought in to work on it too and Isaac
Asimov was as well as a few other
authors and they thought well we'll just
throw these sci-fi
you know it'll turn out good and it
didn't I guess it didn't work at all
but one of the things that did happen
because of that was he was contacted by
at that time a local newspaper reporter
Frank Herbert Wright the doom guy before
he wrote dune and they become really
close friends and they and Paul Anderson
would travel around and go to Mexico and
and and this whole really interesting
story gets get started with the vance's
then move with the Herbert's
to a house in Mexico trying to establish
a writers colony and apparently they
were very rigorous about it you know the
kids had to shut up from a certain
amount of certain time of the day to a
certain time of the day or or get out of
the house so that the writers could be
doing their right early job and they
didn't have kids at that time there were
talk about the Herbert's kids and then
they they come back and notice he's
starting to publish some of his sci-fi
books I don't have any of the like
mystery or or non sci-fi non fantasy
books in this listing there you had
quite a few other ones they buy some
some lots in a house in the hills east
of Oakland out in the countryside and
apparently it was not a very good house
when they bought it it was pretty
rundown it was very small and for about
the next 20 years or so people said
Vance was constantly engaged in one
project or another like building an
extension on it or you know redoing the
floors or fixing the roof and he also
had bad eyesight so you know he'd have
to be really close to what he was
working on in order to do it but he was
constantly puttering away at the house
he has he has a son who's born and then
in 1962 so now we're talking quite a bit
later he and Frank Herbert and Paul
Anderson decide that they want to build
a houseboat not buy a houseboat build a
houseboat and it's not going to be like
a little houseboat it's going to be I
think it was something like
14 by 36 feet so that's a pretty sizable
boat and and they they start working at
it and everything goes wrong and
eventually some of them lose heart but
but they do finally get it to launch the
first time that it launches it actually
I think if I remember right sinks but
they stick with it and they they managed
to use it for some things and around
that time he starts to get some
recognition he wins a Hugo Award for a
short story the dragon masters he'll win
some other Hugo awards later on for the
last castle and starts publishing novels
as Ellery Queen and then notice the the
productivity after that he's starting to
churn out looks and the Vance's would
would do something really interesting
that is his son John Jr talks about he
he said this is his own words they
traveled often to exotic locales madeira
Tahiti Cape Town cashmere they would
settle in cheap lodgings long enough for
Vance to write another book and he said
we'd hole up for anywhere from a couple
of weeks to a few months he had his
clipboard
she had the portable typewriter because
his wife was part of the writing process
and he'd write in longhand and then
she'd type it up first draft second
draft third draft and so the churn out
books and apparently he was quite good
at doing that and so the Sun went all
over the place as a matter of fact he's
got another story about having when
arthur c clarke was living in sri lanka
they stayed with Clark and Clark had to
go and find tutors for the boy so he
could continue his his education must
have been quite a way to live and then
you know he's by the time that we get
into the 70s he's making enough money to
be comfortable as an author he's not he
doesn't have a hardscrabble existence
but you know he's 60 years old by that
time well moving into his 60s right born
in
19:16 so yeah moving into into that and
they start publishing these deluxe
limited hardcover and I should have put
signed editions of works by important
sci-fi and fantasy writers and these two
guys who do this this project they
choose the dying earth as their first
book so that brings this back onto the
scene and you know they start selling
these very nice volumes with a little
signature by Jack Vance but I imagine
are probably worth quite a bit of money
these days I don't know you know I've
never seen one myself but these are by
Tim Underwood and Chuck Miller you do
Wow that would be very interested so
what was the what was the idea behind
this this whole series then well he was
very popular and they just want to make
money so so these guys were primarily
interested in they saw this doesn't
excite fans okay really interesting yeah
I guess there must be quite a good
market for for doing that sort of I'm
sure yeah yeah I'm sort of at the other
end I'm very utilitarian about these
these sorts of things I have to admit so
continuing on with this one of the
things that happens unfortunately in
advance is you know as I said have been
bad to begin with and he starts going to
this doctor who's doing laser surgery
and each operation seems to be fixing it
but it actually makes it worse and by
the end when he says now no more he's
effectively blind so for an author that
that's kind of a big problem but he is
able to work by a dictation for the the
books that come after that there's other
people one of the guy who I wrote my
district
they had to do that himself
Maurice blown down he had a secretary
who would take dictation somebody
actually created a computer program to
do it for him he starts writing more
things and he comes back to the dying
earth stuff in 83 in 84 with the last
two books cordial saga and rial to the
marvelous and you notice he's starting
to get more and more recognition by this
time he's inducted into the
science-fiction Hall of Fame he's a
grandmaster and his production starts to
taper off as I think quite
understandable eventually before he dies
his own wife dies and then there's a
there's a couple other things that
happen in terms of his publication there
is an integral edition of Vance's works
fan funded 45 volume set of his complete
works that that comes out first one is
in 1999 and then in 2012 now that we
have you know the internet going very
strongly spatter light press named after
one of the one of the scales discussed
in in one of his his stories
begins publication of free ebooks and so
that that's something that's that's out
there he dies of what his son calls
complications of old age in his home you
know I think once you're that old
there's a lot of things that can go
wrong and he leaves behind this massive
legacy and but he's still kind of I
think in the sci-fi and fantasy world I
guess you could say it's still a bit
undervalued compared to those other
authors now why would you say because of
the style
fancy like for example she doesn't like
you her yeah yeah so you know that's one
thing and I think also the elaborateness
of his prose yeah
turn some people off it's interesting
because his books are really page
turners yeah watching yeah that's very
literary
yeah it's ideas and you know then you
know that that's various that's a really
interesting observation that if you'd
been a Frenchman or an Italian author or
something like that maybe people would
have said oh this is really so
sophisticated that interval edition was
an interesting thing because it was sort
of a project of the Internet and a new
era of being able to communicate with
people and so the people who put this
together off of a website that they ran
got volunteers to edit okay so if you
were interested they'd send you they'd
send you copies and then you could get
you could edit and it ought to be
approved by advancing his son because
you know they didn't like the way some
editors treated things so they had their
original okay yeah and then the people
who are willing to put them in boxes and
ship them got free free copies in Italy
interesting you know that I mean
projects like that are so massive I mean
the only other one that I can think of
that similar in scope is the Bentham
transcription project with the works of
the English philosopher Jeremy Bentham
there it's not so much editing that the
fans or the volunteers are doing it's
just transcribing stuff from his just
luminous writings and everyone that like
every couple of years or so they
announced that they've got a new book
about them coming out yeah yeah but it
takes so you know getting people to work
together it sounds very easy but every
time you have a big project like that
there's so many so many snarls and he's
also yeah we're gonna talk about that
yeah yeah
now I know more about the game system
itself than about the the books that
came out with you know okay yeah well
let's talk about the world then that he
builds this this dying earth so it is
you know it's a dying earth because it's
a dying Sun it's you know very very far
off he talks in terms of ions and the
Sun is is red now the sky is is you know
sometimes deep blue sometimes pink a lot
of things have changed since you know
the the young present that we live in so
cities have risen and fallen and have
new cities built upon them and they've
you know become great empires and then
fallen and disappeared the human kind is
kind of a small population I guess you
know usually the world is described as
neo medieval but we'd have to expand
beyond European medieval things and
think about you know like the the entire
Islamic world as well I think you could
say is being used mind for for ideas
from this other people describe it as
baroque and it is Baroque but but not in
the
a sense of the time period that we're
thinking about it's more the prose and
the ways in which people are doing
things and the there's no like unifying
theme or or set of customs or anything
that ties all of humanity together in
this there is something that is kind of
curious which is that there's one single
monetary system the terse right and and
and you wonder how that's able to
continue on but it is and it's never
explained exactly how much longer the
earth has to live it could be some
people talk about it some could go out
tomorrow
other people think it'll go on for
thousands of years into the future and
most of the world is in effect back to
the wild or wasteland including areas
that used to be very important and a lot
of institutions like there's a museum
for man that plays an important role in
this stories that's in ruins essentially
there's all sorts of fantastic creatures
some of them are very dangerous
others just kind of humorous and there's
also ghosts and demons and other worlds
and that's an important aspect I think
of the world that he's building as well
there's the possibility of going back
and forth in time but there's also the
possibility of connecting up with other
you call them dimensions or worlds or
whatever you want there is a sort of
which we call vertical dimension to this
there's the overworld which we'll talk
about in a bit and then there's all
these demon worlds beneath and then the
world of humanity's in between but
there's all sorts of other worlds that
you can connect up with which some of
them you know are some of them are good
places and some of them are not so good
and some are quite boring in a way he
talks about one which is empty except
for a moaning sound for example you know
and getting stuck there and there's
never any sort of like rhyme or reason
laid out for them there's there's you
know there's talked about is well you
know this this magical spell or this
object will get you into that world and
make that that possible and but those
are in effect part of his narrative
universe so does his narrative universe
they actually have this would be a good
question to open up for big discussion
does it have some sort of consistent
rules or order to it or is it just kind
of you know people muddle along and make
things up as best as they can
what do you guys think those of you read
a lot of Vance would you say that
there's some sort of a unifying order oh
okay well you what do you guys think is
there there some sort of discernible
logic to it looks like science fiction
stories are also set all in the same
yeah I mean I guess you could yeah you
could say that once he's created
something then the next land over
there's going to be some sort of
connection to it right you could you
could map out the things well so there's
there's something behind this it's not
it's the basis of it is actually science
fiction yeah it reads like fantasy but
the word the earth is really old yeah
and lots of things that happen planets
have been visited some of the people on
earth aren't people they're aliens
people some of these creatures came from
other planets some of them were created
in labs yeah they have their own life
now you know there are a species of
sorts so this is all the the longest you
can just reach back and say well you
know this happened then and thirteen
pinyon and nobody really remembers too
much about it but that's where they were
started yeah so that he can say anything
and there's another universe he has
besides the time for the universe is
called the can reach and that's where
most of the more recent science fiction
takes place okay so the stories there
some of them are linked people cross
over from one book to the other in some
sense yeah so there isn't sure there is
a universe or a cosmos with order you
could say all right but well I would say
that yes yes you read them all and think
about them you'll see that there's
always these of this references to
things that are actually science yeah it
doesn't seem like science because this
is the cultural earth day of the day and
this is the way people think and work
and although the magic is seems like
some kind of supernatural it's actually
based on science yeah and these other
unities these other worlds that they
actual places that exist all right but
you know we just don't know about them
today well that is a great segue into
one of the themes that I was going to
discuss later but we let's jump into and
talk about it now that you could call it
the magic system and yeah there's
there's you know there's a discussion
very early on the very first story about
the nature of magic that it's actually
it is a science it's ultimately based on
mathematics of some sort now what sort
of mathematics I would have a hard time
thinking of it I you know I studied
mathematics as well as philosophy and in
college and you know he and L Sprague de
Kamp and Fletcher Pratt you know when
when they're discussing the mathematics
involved in there Harold Shay stories
it's hard to figure out exactly what
they would have in mind but it is it is
tied in with that sort of idea that goes
all the way back to the pythagoreans and
then you see coming up with Descartes
again that if you could if you really
see the mathematical structures of
things you could manipulate the the
forces of the universe and and
understand it now in the dying earth
they've forgotten most of the spells
were available so you know it's kind of
funny the way that the advance depicts
it and the Wizards use magic primarily
by memorizing these these lengthy
formulas they sort of like clear out of
space in their head
fill it up with the magical stuff and
then recite it and then then it works a
certain thing Cujo is terrible at doing
that he then the few times that he uses
magic he says something wrong and screw
something up but but the other wizards
seem to be able to to do that they also
have you know a lot of different objects
that that have magic and somehow they've
been invested with that and Gary Gygax
he did in fact write quite a bit about
about Vance
and he he actually tried to get him to
come to Gen Con but at that time
Vance's speakers fee was too high to
afford it when it was just starting out
I mean I think if he would have kept the
ad and he probably could have he could
have done it later on and the magic
system in Dungeons and Dragons which was
really the it's not the only major
role-playing system at the time there
was another one that was called his book
that you can find every once in a while
called fantasy war gaming and it dates
to about the same time and it has a
system as well but but Gygax was
developing first it was with tabletop
miniatures and then they started doing
the role-playing aspect of it and when
they started thinking about magic and
you know there's one other things who
that that guy gets that he drew from
from Vance I shouldn't mention that as
well the entire notion of like so in
Dungeons and Dragons you to pick up what
kind of person you're gonna be right
you're a fighter you're a magic user
you're a cleric or you're a thief that
was what the original four classes were
and you had to pick like what do you
want your character to be like and
fighters go around beating everybody up
and killing monsters with swords or axes
and clerics you know cast spells but
they're they're spells to like heal
people or they have a connection with a
deity
magic users are the the wizards or the
the mages or you know whatever you want
to call them and then the thieves are
the people who go around and they don't
just steal things they they figure out
how to undo traps and they're good at
sneaking and and they can do all that
sort of stuff and Gygax said that that
Cujo was one of the main sources of
inspiration for them so that and and
also like you know a few things like the
hobbits and the Lord of the Rings you
know but going back to the magic system
so so Gygax wrote something really
trust in a an article that he wrote in
strategic review in in 76 he's talking
about magic types of magic and he said
there's four basic types of magic and I
think he means like in fantasy narrative
so there's systems which require long
conjuration with much paraphernalia as
an adjunct like those used in
Shakespeare and Macbeth or typically
written about by Robert E Howard in his
Conan stories so that's one kind and
then there's the relatively short spoken
spell as in finished mythology like in
the kalevala or found in the superb is
is he said superb fantasy of Jack Vance
ultra power that's the second the third
is ultra powerful if not always correct
magic typical of decamp and Pratt in
their classic Harold shaped stories and
then he said the generally weak and
relatively ineffectual magic as found in
JRR Tolkien's work now you know you
think about is all the magic and tokens
work like that you know and Sauron makes
the ring maybe not right but but for the
most part that magic that they're doing
compared to the magic that's happening
here or in The Herald Shae stories it's
kind of small isn't it and he said that
that he had to make a decision when he
was put into the other D&D what kind of
magic would it put it be what who's
whose would it resemble and so he chose
the van see and system and that's that's
what you were talking about earlier and
so for everybody who started playing
Dungeons & Dragons from like the 1970s
on they were in effect whether they
realized or no not using a set of ideas
that came from these these stories not
the only thing he mentions the Kalevala
that that sort of thing is happening as
well but so Gygax he calls it the van
see in the system and it's interesting I
remember when I was a kid I was
fascinated with D&D it was very
difficult to find people to play with
living out in the country but when you
did play you you would and he had spent
a lot of time reading these books that
Gary Gygax wrote the Don
masters guide in the player manual and
he had these sort of these little
chapters where he'd talk about what he
was trying to do in creating this what
what is his logic was behind it and he
also had a section where he had reading
recommendations and he said if you
really want to like be a good dungeon
master you need to be literate in in
fantasy literature and Vance was one of
the people that he recommended Fritz
Leiber was another of course you know
Robert Howard of the Conan stories and
there were a whole bunch of other people
but then he if I remember right I
haven't looked at this stuff since I was
a kid he said I like this aspect from
this person this aspect from this person
this aspect from this person
so Vance you know really I mean if you
think about influence D&D is not the
only role-playing game but it's probably
the biggest and it's you know it's sort
of like saying you know the US isn't the
only military but what we decide to do
influences every other military right
what would happen with D&D where magic
plays an absolutely central role
arguably influenced all the other
developments of face to face
role-playing games and then through that
all the computer you know multiplayer
role-playing games that people are
playing this whole this whole notion of
how spells should work for a couple
spin-off okay maybe five six novels
they're very good Wow she's I haven't
read either one of them that would be
something interesting to follow up did
she write a lot of other stuff or okay
but that was the main stuff that he did
he had a character like Google and and
got trouble and what was his name the
character you don't love him great one
for a long time I've got some little
okay yeah that would be fun to to check
out so the magical system is is
something you know it's a very important
part of the books actually now now that
we're talking about roguish characters
that was another theme i wanted to bring
up was is is who joel and some of the
other characters in here are they are
they echo or are they just simply amoral
are they they're not yeah yes so I think
that's that takes it a little bit beyond
just just the only what serves itself
there's there's a kind of it's not
asceticism because because qoodles
willing to be happy with whatever comes
along right he's not finicky about
things too much the way some of the
other characters are you know
that's his that's his yeah I mean he's
always in the stories the money is
coming quickly and then he loses that
almost all yeah do you think that he
really does enjoy the act of like
tricking people or getting he there's a
line in one of the stories where
somebody asked him is this the conduct
of a sly and unpredictable villain and
he says decidedly so if the villain for
the purposes of his joke thinks to
simulate the Alturas the person who's
you know other oriented who's trying to
help other people and then the other guy
says well how would you know the villain
from the altruist then and then it says
who Jill shrugged it is not an important
distinction so now what about the other
characters in in here they definitely
have motives some of them seem to be you
know some of them are clearly bad
characters they intent harm to other
people a few of them seem to be pretty
altruistic they they offer what's that
altruistic I'm thinking about like and
well they're not purely altruistic right
there's usually some sort of deal being
struck but the guy and I forget his name
he well he actually he's willing to pull
fast ones on people
there's a story where there is a guy and
he builds these platforms for the men in
the village to sit on and and you know
you you want to have your platforms as
high as possible and they're they're
associating with like healthful living
but it's really about being more
important than yeah and the women will
do just about anything to get the
stonecutter who has he what he thinks is
a magical amulet it's really the boots
that have the magic because the boots
have a special wax that's put on them
you kick the the stone or kick anything
else and it like floats it the weight is
taken from it and so he's been able to
he's the last of a series of stone
cutters who are able to you know
establish themselves in in that town and
so the women are like you know making
him food and bringing him all sorts of
stuff so that he will do his job and
make these you know these these
essentially what would you call them
they're they're they're almost like
wrongs you know they're not a ladder
they're just pieces that that that you
you put together and make a larger tower
now when Google Google shows up he takes
them in and he doesn't put him to work
right away he says here you can have
some food I've got plenty of it you can
stay the night if you want to he seems
pretty altruistic doesn't he guy who
doesn't want to suggest that everybody's
on the mate
they're not always good at it and some
of them don't care that much one way or
another somebody's out for anybody they
put themselves and/or their tongue yeah
sometimes or they're religious right and
that's yeah sorry the kind of that best
a moralism running throughout the entire
thing yeah that's right minutes funny
yes the trust speaks and they sound so
serious and you know he's not he's not
really trying to put it over on people
so much as just try to be you know a
handsome this guy gets the best women
and maybe a better age than anybody else
yeah but you know he's he said of less
nasty than the others one of the things
that got pointed out by some of the
common ters about Google is that he
thinks he's much better with the women
and more attractive and a greater lover
than he actually is and I don't remember
which story it is but there's one where
the women really lay into they they say
he was terrible you know we were we were
just going along with things to get
something out of you and it doesn't
bother him he's he just continues
thinking that he's he's great anyway
yeah
tendencies or whatever well--that's he's
not he's not narcissistic in the way
that a lot of narcissists are where
they're out of touch with reality and
they can't they can't function very well
because they make stupid mistakes right
he he does still make mistakes doesn't
really respond to things that he doesn't
agree with and even even is there really
any true altruism there's some things
like know not only hell that's no I mean
even in any sense because even if you're
doing it for the best of reasons you're
still getting something oh yeah you know
you're you're so getting something
you're getting some pleasurable aspect
from doing something for whatever
reasons you do it so you know there's
like really slimy like apparently you
would say this crucial guy yes sir
there's no well there's slimy characters
in that yet and in some of these stories
yeah well that so that another theme I
wanted to talk about was so earth might
be dying but human beings the human race
seems to be doing quite quite well and I
wanted to bring up the idea that so you
know we often talked about there's human
nature right and we we say there's a
common human condition that we all look
one way or another inhabit or we might
say there's there's some sort of human
comedy or drama that we're all playing
little roles in so maybe we don't all
have to be exactly the same but we we
fit you know we're all gonna die someday
we face up to certain basic constants
and in in this story you know there's a
set of stories there's all sorts of
orientations and occupations depicted or
envisioned of the people they can have
different motives some are you know very
into some sort of religious perspective
you know there's there's a group that
are actually doing something that I I
guess you could say they think is is in
some way altruistic they're beaming
energy at the Sun it's not doing
anything
but the other places in the world that
are supposed to be doing that they've
all they've all died out or disappeared
but there is this group that that's
oriented towards you know beaming things
at the Sun and they take that very very
seriously their societies organized
around that and there's a bunch of other
ones as well so you know can we say that
here's here's the thing we could think
about so advance of course is in our
time he's imagining something that would
be very distant and is he just
projecting our own ideas and categories
on to a distant dying earth and we we
like it in part because you know we can
see something that's that's similar to
other literature whereas you know
there's there's other authors who
imagine what humanity is going to be
like way in the future and they're like
we couldn't even connect with them we
can't imagine what they would be like
yeah these people are just people right
yeah future humans they've been involved
in any sense of like regular accepting
differently yeah and that's an
interesting thing people criticize them
for that Faraz he's not trying to create
a real a realistic far future at all
yeah I was trying to create a humorous
sub-stories fantasy scenario that sells
and sell books and
you have a political axe to grind in any
of this yeah they none whatsoever all I
wanted to do was songs yeah and any sod
that is from what I've read of stuff he
saw that as you didn't even say that
everybody needs to be like that he just
saw that as that's a great way to be an
author you know that's a great way to
orient yourself so I mean if you compare
him against like so many like Clark
right you think about childhood
childhoods and where we can't even
picture what this Overmind is like and
that's the end of the human race this is
something very different than that this
is like you said it's people doing the
same kind of stuff as they did in our
lifetime or did back in the Middle Ages
and we could ask do we do we think human
beings are gonna be like that if we do
manage to live into the distant future I
mean if we don't die out as a race
something about the new sign
Oh June will feel it was a very similar
thing to that it was you know a billion
years in the future and one of the
things I brought up to is why is it that
people never Chami
all of this goes on you know all of this
technology but then all of a sudden you
lose all the technology like this so
yeah what goes back to medieval that was
the same thing that you moved it I mean
why is it that she would have forgotten
everything and you're back to fighting
with swords and sticks and doing this
kind of nonsense and you yeah it has not
evolved yeah and obviously we are going
to evolve we have always evolved and we
have the discussion before that we may
at some point just you know evolve until
they can a eyesore
just upload consciousness and become
mechanized but and or we could depending
I mean if it would go back to such a
situation where it was almost medieval
where it was like the Dark Ages we lost
everything then we would probably not
evolve because our check would be gone
any other conditions that are required
to to be when you're talking about
evolving you're talking about like
society which is the matrix for the
individuals evolving to offer new
possibilities because I mean if you
think about what's required in order to
have the technology let's say we're
gonna upload our consciousness as we get
past the problem of whether that's
possible or not think about the sheer
infrastructure that's required to make
that make that happen
there's people alive today there is
certain they're gonna there themselves
are gonna do it now II know yeah gonna
happen I mean they're they're it's it's
you know something that's potential yeah
so if we're I'm going with this if we do
if we do evolve it's going to require a
certain degree of like not just
stability but you know things proceeding
along in an orderly manner and and you
get the idea that's that in his view of
this that did happen but then you know
give it long enough and things break
down sooner or later you know but I
wonder if that isn't more I mean we're
here is it saying that's more accurate
well who what would be the measure for
the let's see them to the future right
Erica's very speculative
well this yellow I mean this all is I
mean just but if you look at things how
they have gone to this point what there
has to be some kind of
brings it back to the point where you
are you know going back into the dark
ages like city on top of City on top of
City but your cities are regressing
instead of progressing and you're in
your everything else is kind of
regressing you know if you're if you're
going if you're interplanetary moving
around you obviously you've got some
ability to do that but you know at the
same time you're swinging a sword you
know I mean that that's it yeah yeah I
guess that's just possess a story you
know somebody you know a lot of good I
think that would depend on being able to
continually harness energy right and
being able to rely on that to keep
everything going
you know we're gonna sooner or later
after this shift away from fossil fuels
because we although we keep finding new
new deposits of them sooner or later
we're gonna know the use of them yes
well will the planet will die before we
and ran out of fossil fuels just
basically well that's good news but yeah
in order to - I mean sci-fi people
always solve this by just having some
new energy source or you know explaining
it away but in if we think about how it
would have to happen for us in order to
have the evolution in order to supply
all that computing power I mean think
about how much electricity is consumed
just with these server farms that we
have to ship our Amazon project products
you know I think the prospects of having
some sort of future where we would all
be uploaded into the cloud would
probably take more than that
I said this would be slow yeah so yeah
you're not accepted to the cold fusion
level about this I would say yeah yeah
to do that or yeah you have to start
using something like the center is some
kind of a fusion to get that level of
and if we don't then maybe we do end up
having a shift back into older formats
you know I mean what we're seeing with
wealth inequality in our own time is
sort of a regression to the mean
you know the the here in the United
States we had a great you know after the
World War two we had a great you know
boom period where standards of living
were increasing you know pretty much
across the board and and then you know
we hit a peak and it started going down
with Generation X it became more
difficult for them to pay for schooling
by you know buy a house and now we're
seeing more difficulties for the newer
generation and and I think in part I was
very far afield now if of the original
discussion but what we're seeing is a
reversion back to the mean because
that's the way it is in most societies
through history we have these incredibly
stratified societies we had a nice
honeymoon period I guess of 4050 years
and it doesn't look like we managed to
use it all that well in a way that would
make it sustainable so now maybe we're
moving moving back to those those sort
of things you know which is not good
everything's connected on the dang web
so every every that would bring us to
dark ages that way yeah you know another
thing that could really screw us up and
you do see sight like like horror people
exploring this just a really bad
pandemic because you think about what's
required in order to maintain
the the current level of activity that
we have you don't just need all the
massive amounts of technology and energy
and energy consumption we also do we are
pretty labor-intensive we still do need
a lot of human beings but at least
pushing buttons well I mean you know it
wouldn't it wouldn't necessarily to be a
zombie thinking you just always so many
people died I mean just so many people
work on if you think about like let's
say you take some of the the major
diseases that we have and let's say you
boosted them up a bit and they became
favourite viruses they're resistant to
all the antivirals that are out there
and they hit the sort of sweet spot
because you know interna have a really
good pandemic and good in the sense of
like being able to spread it can't be so
deadly that it kills all the hosts like
that that's one problem with like Ebola
for example you know if you kill all the
whole straightaway you can't spread very
far that's why I like things like
cholera or the Black Death these things
that originally come out of the Indian
subcontinent once they they really
became deadly they didn't kill all the
population but they killed enough of the
population to bring things to a halt in
many respects and and if we hit
something like that with our incredibly
technology dependent civilization what
do we do would we just like use machines
to supplement all the people
they've already discovered see area in
Europe and it's gonna head over here and
when that does this is this consume
resistant equal aid by the time they
don't area by giving you there will be
no antibiotic they will be able to treat
anything so people will die from cutting
their fingers on a knife I mean there is
they'll be no and they're already this
is already appearing and so there it's
yeah there's a possibility if they don't
well that'll be like again a reversion
to the norm the way it was for most
humans I mean warfare throughout most of
history a lot of the casualties came
because of wounds that became infected
or just stubbing their toe or seventy
percent of people that died men that
died they were fighting in the Civil War
died of disease yeah yeah I also heard a
thing IVC early this morning did you
gotta get up one of the other themes
that I had wanted to talk about was I
call it sort of taking perspective and
perspectives play an important role in
in a lot of these stories and the idea
is that maybe the perspectives can
create the world that you're living it
or at least the experiences that you
have right so the the entire first you
know who gel book is about trying to get
these eye pieces that let you see
they're called the eyes of the overworld
they let you see this world in terms of
the the overworld
so you could and they they don't just
affect your vision they affect like all
your sensorium so you can eat crappy
food and think that you're dining on
wonderful stuff you could hear terrible
screeching and think you're hearing
beautiful music you could be like
rolling around on marbles and think that
you know you're getting a wonderful
massage or whatever else is going on and
one of the people who is experiencing
this kugels talking to him and he says
yes I realize I see but assemblance but
so do you and who's to say which one is
real the idea is if it's if it's real
for you if you're experiencing it isn't
that just as good as you know being in
the real world and and experiencing the
things there so that that I think that's
one important way that he's playing
around with this idea and everybody
wants to get their hands on these
glasses because they I mean it's almost
like a drug right it makes your reality
so much yeah you know there's talking
about that or not just there are some
like there are some characters like that
in in these stories they usually tend to
be the ones that are into philosophy or
religion like there's that guy who on
this caravan he's constantly you know
talking about the different infinities
all coming together in this one place
and you should contemplate that and then
everybody else is like well you're no
fun to drink with you know it's like
well I'm not supposed to be fun to to
drink with I'm doing something better
another one of the the very first story
has a creature in it a woman who was
created in an in a vat and there was her
brain gets screwed up somehow then she
has her own story later on and she sees
the universe in a way different than we
do everything looks disgusting to her
everything looks horrifying and she's
filled with
just sort of hatred and rage and wants
to kill everybody and destroy everything
and I think she's one of the most
interesting characters because she she's
able to find out that her way of looking
at things is actually wrong that she's
out of touch with reality even though
she's experiencing something terrible
all the time so she like you should look
at this around the table it should be
like look at those of those ghouls or
goblins and then she's got a sword
should probably try to kill all of us or
you know this light is a sickly light
you know and she she changes over time
she's trying to find beauty in a world
that that she knows Beauty exists but
she can't see it and I think it's a
fascinating character in part because of
the self consciousness of that if you if
she didn't know when she was just like a
on the on the hunt trying to kill things
she wouldn't be quite so interesting
yeah do you think that yeah you're right
do you think that she needs to hear she
needs the somebody being like her enough
to be able to hear that message yeah she
had killed her she still should have
been stuck in the same dynamic yeah yeah
yeah another thing that came up in
another story again in the first book is
this this guy is asking an auger about
fees and the auger said I respond to
three questions for twenty Tauruses I
phrased the answer and clear in
actionable language for ten I use the
language of Kant which occasionally
admits of ambiguity for five I speak a
parable which you must interpret as you
will and for one turist I babble it an
now we're not talking about like visual
perception now right we're talking about
how people learn about the world and and
I think it's fascinating that so he
knows what somebody's future is or what
they ought to do right and he's willing
to share it with you and if you pay the
full price if you get the gold package
as we often say right then you get clear
and actionable language yeah there
there's one god I can only think of one
case where a God does something
genuinely good and it's that God who's
totally just right he gives everybody
justice and so he gives this guy who's
faced back that is a witchy
ex-wife or paramour had taken away
through her sorcery but then gives her a
terrible you know look herself but all
the other gods are either you know they
don't care about human beings or they're
they're kind of they almost look like
demons or you know now that their
followers are just as bad
some of them you know don't believe in
any of the stuff that they're they're
spouting and the ones that do are almost
worse now one of the things I thought
was interesting about his his stories is
and this is all throughout his writing
yeah that people travel and with a good
places they don't know what they're
gonna run into yeah it's very it's a
very awkward and
compromising dangerous possible
situation and the people that we need
take advantage of them they don't know
yeah so there's always this dilemma so
implicit negotiation as a travel there's
this there's this very humorous usually
negotiation about how to get lodging and
how to get what you're looking for and
how to find directions and the people
say well you know our customs we might
not we might not be able to tell you
everything you want to know but why
don't you stay the night and then you
find out there the next day's sacrifice
yes
that's well there's another one great
one to her they he stays in the town
he's trying to get back to where he's
supposed to be originally and he stays
in this town and they say oh you know
there's this tower and the keeper of the
tower just died today is his place is
open and wow he lives this wonderful
life you know he's the best food sleeps
with anybody he wants to and they talk
it up so much and so qoodles like well
could I apply for the job and so so he
doesn't once he gets up in the tower
they pull the Rope down and they give
him really crappy food when they give
him any food yeah well you know yeah
you're right he always gets some revenge
right I guess coudl himself and and some
of the others they also McCree eight
perspectives through words they they get
one over on people don't they by
creating the prospect of greater gain or
comfort or pleasure ease or whatever
else that people are are driven by once
you figure out on an advantage and
yeah so that's all that I actually had
in terms of you know themes well what
else really struck those of you have
read these stories what else do you
think in terms of philosophical themes
in a broad sense needs to be brought up
is there anything that you think is
missing so let me ask this is it is it
is it changing in the sense of like it's
moving from one workable configuration
to another workable configuration or is
it more like a decline where there is
there is originally a logic and order a
structure and now it's breaking down and
there's a lot of gaps and things don't
fit together that well and anybody can
kind of take advantage when they want is
it is what the one or is it the other
logic and technology actually stopped
working it's an interesting series
because the stopped working totally
Matthew Hughes one of those are good yes
the universe that's what happens that
that there are phases of logic and
science and then there
is of magic and rationality and they
alternate and when what is going and the
other is coming people get caught in the
middle and it's very interesting the
stories are based on that how long do
the cycles go on for where it's it's
magic or okay kind of explains how you
get from interesting I think you know if
I remember right Roger Zelazny has a
story where like order completely is
broken down the main character is all
ticked off because again you know things
just are floating and and he's he's
trying to restore order to things and
the I mean the good news is is that the
agents of chaos there they can't
actually get it together to stop him
because well they're well there's the
Chronicles of amber and you know there's
a short story of his but I mean you
could say The Chronicles of amber are
also dealing with that same problem
right it's it's this this conflict
between amber representing order and
chaos which was there before amber and
then you know what happens after the
patterns been destroyed and we when we
discussed that one that was in the first
year I talked about it in terms of
neoplatonism and the idea of like
emanation of order and structure outward
from in that case the pattern but for
the neoplatonist the one the the thing
and in that one you have a character who
after the pattern has been racked his
way of fixing things is to create a new
pattern which introduces a third aspect
third element right between order and
chaos doesn't turn out to be completely
a stable resolution though then he
writes another five volumes yeah yeah
yeah they were good years ago I think
the first five were probably better than
the last five why would it you guys
might say yeah well anything else you
guys want to say about Vance or anything
else he went when the science-fiction
channel was really doing science fiction
oh yeah ports from conventions yeah so
that's got the Grandmaster Awards I only
had a little five-minute spiel on what
was going on and there he was sent here
and he said it's about time I went to
see him when in for the World Fantasy
Award yeah and he was just really a nice
guy
yeah founder and he told us he told us
you know we had everybody wanted to know
how to pronounce C Mooji you know What
did he say
okay but he said I think that's great
yeah how long did you get to talk with
him well pretty long actually and
because I was an anthropologist and in
those days I was an anthropologist
okay he's very interested in
anthropology and there's a lot of
anthropology in here yeah a lot of
culture yeah conflict and a lot of you
know he doesn't go on and on bore you
with details of stuff that you need to
know for the story yeah like about it
and it's just enough like that cherry
that you read was that last week oh yeah
yeah yeah that's month yeah yeah yeah I
tried some of hers and she's
oh yeah because of that language over my
head and you come out to San Francisco
there with my while he was blind
oh yeah why I had the idea that he was
legally blind and yeah you know I but
you know he could see right in front of
him and that's how you use that screen
which is like really nearsighted I guess
and very obese and such a fan base like
you know you wouldn't believe in people
argument about it yeah but they all say
advances in to everybody well that's the
I think they think that's that's quite
right that is a great story to end on so
thanks for for bringing that up you know
it's not often that I brought you
something else to see really yeah
where do you work where's your story and
that story I still on mining in antique
malls but okay you know that's
interviewer there in the 1990s and
further this was the most expensive
paperback you could buy if you really
the paperbacks that is really do you
mind if I take a picture
[Music]